Low Freak bitches,
everybody's so freaked out
and heroin was more of like an eyelash
for the vagina,
for periods and stuff.
So when wouldn't get everywhere and
that's why girls are,
that's not what it is.
The uh,
the butthole hair was always disturbing
though.
Yeah.
I don't like nobody ever liked the
buddle here because some girls just did
not know what they were doing when it
came to wiping.
And back then nobody had a bad day and
nobody had baby wipes.
It was toilet paper.
Sometimes some of it stuck around.
So you get this little joints for a
little gi.
Joe figures
super tightly rolled up.
Did you know those little shit joint?
Yeah.
Could you know those little notes?
Trimmers that you buy?
You use that for your asshole also.
You can't.
Yeah,
I was unaware of the.
Well,
it's not rocket science.
It's not like trying to figure out solar
power,
nose hair trimmers on your eyes.
It's just if it cuts hair cuts,
hair,
it just does.
And it doesn't like cut you and stuff.
Well,
couldn't you get like one of those face
shavers?
A little nice ones down there with your
ass.
So you have a shaving your ass here.
Oh,
I just leave my girls.
You know what though?
You could do a way better job of
cleaning it if you're an asshole is
shaved,
but your asshole will grow that hair
back like wild Bush and then in a couple
days you'll be just squeezing your ass
cheeks everywhere you go to keep from
just digging in there,
brushing.
Just clawing at your asshole like a wolf
trying to bury a Caribou.
That stubble and ball stubble.
All stumbles are.
How come they face?
Double?
Barely bothers me.
My head stubble does it.
Like I got a of double up here right
now.
No,
it doesn't bother me at all.
But Jesus Christ,
my asshole.
Moving around in your chair when you
wipe your ass and he grabbed like a
bundle of hair on the way out.
You know it's the best man.
One Wipe Charlie's.
You ever tried that?
I want them so bad but it's like a dude
wipe.
Like that kind of a thing.
Like a baby wipe they made.
They made for men,
but they don't smell like flowers.
Like you just got asked by a flower for
it anymore.
Yeah.
Well I.
That Japanese thing is the shit man.
Isn't gonna install one in here?
Yeah.
I'm going to install it in here
eventually.
Does it shoot
the shit hanging out for an hour?
He's a high pressure wind pressure,
water.
Warm Air.
It dries your asshole off.
There's two different speeds to the
water shoots in your asshole totos.
It also cleans your vagina.
If you're a Gal,
he cleans your badge area.
You can back your badge up,
get a little tingly,
tingly,
and if you know a little time and you
know.
Do you went to Joseph Cao?
We went to Japan.
I just sat there for seriously for a
half hour with the one shooting in my
asshole because it just felt so because
it hit like the back wall,
but hold that long.
I'd have to do it to feel like I was
getting clean.
I still have to do paper afterwards.
No,
no.
You didn't walk out with worried.
It was so clean.
I mean it was like taking a shower for
your butthole.
Yeah,
pretty meticulous.
You not doing as good a job.
I'm telling you,
you're just mirroring.
Even if you're using baby wipes,
you just smearing.
Show over your hair.
Okay.
Imagine if I took some shit and I just
rubbed into the top of your head.
You like,
I'm good.
I got a baby wipe.
But if I had never you would never
accept that.
But if I get in the shower and you would
clean your asshole here,
fair enough.
But.
But if you told me,
you told me I had 70 baby wipes and a
roll of toilet paper.
I take a shoulder again,
shower.
Jesus Christ.
That was a choice.
This fork and shit all day too.
Don't worry about it.
I rubbed it with 70 baby wipes.
I be like,
that's not enough.
You've got to watch this fucking thing.
You got to get it in the washing
machine.
I didn't these hot water and Sun.
But again,
let's say baby wipes and paper,
just trying to get my method approved.
It's still shit.
Pick shower after the shower.
It's
unfair to say.
I mean,
I don't do anything.
I don't go out for the day though,
until I shower after I stand up or to
wipe or sit down,
stand up and sitting down even a
possibility.
Fuck wipes or asked.
Sitting down.
You must have cuffs.
Cuffs.
I don't do it.
He does.
I wanted you to do,
man.
I stayed in that.
Find a target.
Stand up,
stand up.
Stand up or sit down.
No,
there's people.
Most people sit in their sleeves,
smelled or watch.
Guarantee you.
One more quick.
One of my buddies told me he goes from
the front between his smell,
his balls.
Oh yeah.
Christ.
You don't.
He's going to have some.
Damn.
Do you pay attention to all of the
scientific research that's being done in
genetic engineering and changing?
Is there anything?
Yeah.
Like um,
they actually identified the dwarf gene,
like they've been able to identify the
gene that causes dwarfism.
And this debate has gone on as their,
as the technology keeps getting closer
to the point where we can actually do
this,
but there's a debate going is if we can
remove that gene,
if we can prevent your child from having
dwarfism,
should we.
And a lot of dwarves were like,
no,
we shouldn't do it.
It's playing God,
it's stump up and,
and I'm,
I'm there going,
yeah,
you should absolutely remove it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Why would you want your kid to go
through?
I mean,
granted I've been lucky at like,
like I said,
I've only had like one surgery and I
made a good career with the hand that I
was dealt,
but there's a lot of little people I
know that,
that haven't,
that don't.
And then get constantly made of their
entire lives are hidden away by their
parents.
Why would you want your kid to go
through that and as a dwarf,
you know,
what struggles that you had growing up,
why would you,
why would you intentionally put those
pains on your child?
I don't understand that.
I don't.
It's hard to understand a lot of
decisions that people make,
a lot of rationalizations that people
may.
Yeah,
like,
um,
like one reason that I'm able to be a
comedian and sort of have this sense of
humor about it is because my dad was
amazing,
is amazing.
Like when I was born he found out that I
was going to be a dwarf so he would go
to these LPA little people of America
meetings and he would find out about it
and he was like,
Oh shit,
my kid's gonna get made fun of a lot.
Like his life is going to be weird.
So his philosophy was when I was growing
up,
he would make fun of me first,
but he would do it in a supportive way.
Like he would fuck with me,
but then say,
okay,
I just insulted you,
hit me back with something,
hit me back and then get.
Because this is going to happen to you
later.
Bye.
Was like training you.
Yeah.
So by the time I got to kindergarten I
like,
I remember kindergarten walking in in a,
a kid just laughing at me going,
hi,
you're little.
And I looked at him and went,
ah,
your mom doesn't live with your dad
anymore.
And kindergarten and kindergarten and
fucking like,
I got sent to the principal's office for
like,
like hurting this kid's feelings.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and they call my deadline like we're
going to call your father.
I'm like,
fucking do it.
You trained you to be a comedian.
Kind of did.
Because now like when I get a heckler,
it's like,
do you think you're going to say
anything to me that I haven't heard on
the street that I haven't heard walking
down and some kid having,
like saying a comment like I've had.
I've had parents bring their children up
to me when the line is too long at the
mall Santa and go,
hey,
tell this guy what,
what you want.
I've had that happen to mayor.
I
want to talk to you about some shit
dude.
I was working out in my gym yesterday
dying.
Okay.
All I'm doing is hitting pads.
No one's hitting me back.
I'm fucking exhausted.
And when I like to do,
when I'm,
when I'm working out is I like to put
fights on for motivation and I'm
watching you and you're,
you're fighting in the last man standing
tournament.
You got to fight three times this.
This night.
You're,
you're fighting you,
you're going for fucking rounds.
Exhausting,
ridiculous fight.
And then our member,
this shit.
Oh Shit.
Oops,
I just dropped elvis.
Elvis has left the building.
I remember this shit.
Brian sent me this picture.
What the fuck dude.
How are you able to have that kind of
cardio?
I mean,
you fought three times that night for
four rounds.
The first fight before you.
You won by knockout and you're,
you're smoking cigarettes.
Yeah.
How's that possible?
Oh Joe,
I didn't want to talk about this last
time.
When was this?
When was the cigarette?
That cigarette was right after the fight
with,
uh,
Robert Thomas in the dressing room.
Ryan lochte Loco.
Shut up in my dressing room before I got
in the shower.
And it was like taking pictures and I'm
like,
he's like,
can I,
can I take,
I won't take a photo on my grind.
Just take the picture.
Here it is.
Now.
When you fought in a tournament,
you didn't have any cigarettes in
between fights or anything.
Did you have to assignment?
I went outside and had a
true story.
Oh my God.
You got a cigarette and then fought
twice more.
Yeah.
It's coming to an end up getting really
sick of smoking and I'm getting really
sick of explaining,
having this conversation.
Joe Joe's the reason when I quit.
This will be the reason.